hey there and welcome to pro flows
number 45 I'm Cameron and this one is
called blobs and let me show you why
I've got blob number one here which is
just a shape layer that's filled with
pink as you can see here and I've got
shape layer number two which is blob
number two also filled with pink now let
me show you the trick here this is the
cool part so we're going to create a new
adjustment layer and this is just our
effects layer and we're going to go to
effect and we're going to go to blur and
sharpen fast box blur and we're just
going to crank this up to eight and
we're apply one more effect which is
under mat and it's called simple choker
and there it is and we're going to set
this to be the same number as our blur
radius so this is the blur radius is 8
so let's set this to 8 as well and there
we go now watch what happens I'm gonna
go ahead and lock this layer whenever I
move blob 1 & 2 close together they
create a blob effect and what's pretty
cool about this effect is you can
increase the amount of kind of like
liquid blob enos between these all you
have to do is go back into your
adjustment layer and you could like
theoretically make this a number 30 and
then make the choke mat 30 as well and
it does make your blobs smaller the
higher you increase these numbers but at
the same time it creates more of a
liquid effect between these blobs and
that's all it is it's uh it's really fun
to play around with this to animate it
and make these liquid blobs do blobby
motion